[Music]
you guys know the Univision channel you
remember them
hell Channel 34 they ran out of money
right no oh maybe they did I don't know
they defin weather well they're still
out there doing news so they ended up in
Chicago where they were doing a news
coverage on uh like the increase of
robberies and like violent uh like theft
and uh in the middle of it they got
robbed at gunpoint for the cameras and
and their money oh [__] they were
covering the robbery of the coverage
yeah is that like good news though
classic I don't think it's good news was
it live I think it marks now the second
time in 3 weeks that a news crew was
robbed while covering robbery in Chicago
yeah but I just saw a viral video Yeah
of a a dad who was in Chicago and his
bit was like I heard Chicago so bad and
he's like hanging out like the most
popular tourist attraction he's like
yeah Chicago's so bad right now and he's
like in front of the Chicago Bean like
everything it's fine he's like it's so
[__] out here so like it's probably
fine cuz that guy went that guy went to
a very popular tourist area in the
middle of the day at 2:00 p.m. was good
yeah and he proved it wasn't there one
where there's like there a news that's
covering like oh the crime and then
there was a driveby shooting that
happened oh that that one breaks my
heart dude cuz the lady was she started
praying yeah oh she was just like get
down she was like Cal she was like a
city official she was like giving an
interview and then the someone did a
driveby by the park and then she she
tells everyone to get down and then she
starts praying it's really like sweet
why is Chicago so [__] up right now
what happens not according to the guys
no it's not it's not it's all an
illusion yeah it's just it's right-wing
media the this is the second time second
time in 3 weeks this from the same from
the same network no it's a different
network was doing coverage about the
robberies and they got robbed well maybe
that became a thing cuz you robbed the
first one you're like nothing happened
hey there's another news one let's get
that good money last time yeah you're
right see the taco trucks that are
getting robbed too now before it was
just the shoplifting where they just run
in the stores and grab [__] but now
they're like hitting mom and pop shops
and like taco trucks where's the Mexican
Mafia I Thought They protected those
guys the fruit car people they protect
them for sure who can answer that can
you Anthony just a rhetorical where's
the Mexican Mafia man where are they
probably in
montabella it is kind of funny that like
I mean I mean where is all the gangs in
Mafia that used to defend these types of
things right I think they're not paying
the protection money they're the ones
doing it now or they're just not in
Chicago or they're all probably
streaming or something dude the economy
sucks they're they're probably they
can't P they can't pay for it oh they're
in jail all the old school gangsters and
everyone that used to like have
territory and all that they all went to
jail and it was like a time of peace
that we've seen in
LA and then this happens M yeah damn
well yeah it's not getting any better
what new stations would you guys like to
Rob
Anthony um La
18 what news
stations no it's okay you don't have to
answer it it was just more of
aor I wouldn't Rob UPN I'd be like they
have you guys
took I feel kind of bad and [__] cuz you
know news stations and all these guys
they're already broke and they're
already like they're already like
failing and dying and [__] and then like
people are going to like all these
journalists and everyone they're going
to be out of the job right and then
they're getting robbed out of all their
equipment what are they going to do now
buy new equipment also are they like
aren't those like pretty big heavy
cameras like why you even get anything
for that maybe they could sell it to
other new
stations the one that just got like
robbed the week before they went on
Craigslist they're like dude SEL K yeah
dude there's a Channel 4 one it's a
black market system yeah was this
midday or they trying to
yeah it is midday was it going to be a
black mark yeah it was
Midday why do you think like that dude
punching down all the time with your
comments punching down from my from my
white Ivory Tower you think always man
always think hey can you come down to
the minorities down here economy class
or the minorities who are in the
majority in the world yeah
sure I'll come around to that whose
world huh whose World China's World dude
you guys own our president you colonize
I've been reading on Gateway pundit I'm
over here next to [__] two [__]
feudal imperialist colonies hey what
happened in Hawaii Bart tell the world I
don't know anything talk about Oprah
what's up with Oprah subing is
crazy don't do it it's like watching a
whole team play dodgeball and everyone's
running away yeah and the ball sitting
in the middle of the corner that was me
that was me deflecting the ball with the
ball and then it goes to somebody else
just this the whole
game yeah so uh obviously every time
this happens you you hear someone throw
a stat out about how like well I mean if
you look at the stats robbery's actually
down 7% since last year cuz they're not
being reported dumbass yeah it's if you
don't if you don't catch and convict
then you can report no crime that's not
on my feet on my feet it's like things
are places are getting robbed and
burglarized constantly the people who
use that talking point the most are rich
people honestly like rich people who are
like on the news and they're like oh
yeah well actually like [__] if you
look at it compared to the'80s it's
crime has been falling and falling and
falling it's like cool go tell that to
the business owner who just like got
wrecked and insurance isn't filling
their claim like go go go do that yeah I
think especially like you always say
like at a time where your dollar goes
the least distance it ever has and
you're getting jacked it's a bigger
[__] effect when you get robbed than
it was in the 80s damn right it's kind
of crazy because it's like they're
obviously doing it for like everybody
does this stuff usually for a bigger
reason like feeding families or feeding
your kids I mean the murder rate is not
as high as it used to be right it's just
mostly theft and people just trying to
survive right it's like it's kind of
jacked but I kind of feel bad but
they're inflating your dollar every day
they don't give a [__] we've been
worrying about it for years on this show
and and meanwhile the the price to even
buy equity in anything actual own assets
going through the roof oh yeah by the
way you can't even loan we won't loan
you money cuz the rates just went up all
the way Skyhigh right and they might
even raise them more so now you're
priced out of the market guess what
you've been working your ass off you had
a nest egg you wanted to buy a house uh
uh just Out Of Reach just Out Of Reach
just Out Of Reach by the way crypto is a
scam not your financial system it's
crypto that's a scam something that
can't be controlled by a central entity
something that gets printed by an entity
that is decentralized all these
different miners all around the world
that's what owns Bitcoin not the [__]
central banks or anything that's why
they're all looking to getting a Bitcoin
through ETFs the financial Revolution is
happening in front of your eyes yeah
Oprah it always like resonates a ton
when you say um like the position that
you're in in order to get a good
foothold in society now financially is
harder than ever so any setback is
bigger than ever too so it's like if you
get [__] digging out now versus like
the 80s or 90s like that way different
but why don't you pull up yourself up by
your bootstraps right that's the thing
that is a fallacy look I agree with
that's the fallacy I agree with the idea
of it right you can work your way out of
problems right I love that idea but when
the system the pressure of the system is
weighing down you so hard and they're
inflating the the the dollar every
single day they're Printing and printing
and printing their way out of all this
stuff but then Co happens and they want
to give you no money oh look at Hawaii
actually they want to give you $700
you're not going to get [__] we're going
to give Ukraine billions of dollars no
[__] problem US citizens you're
[__] we'll give you $700 deal with it
no more help is coming literally they
said that that's the scam that's true
our system is a [__] joke and then
they use use the news to weaponize like
oh yeah but the system is that's the
only way to win actually this crypto
stuff that's the fugazi you're [__]
like and then they have Jim Kramer
telling you what to buy and what to sell
every day on and if you follow his [__]
you're
done literally you're going to be even
more that's you got to follow yeah
follow reverse Kramer dude successful up
reverse Kramer's up really yeah it's
been up it's it's like a fun that does
everything opposite of what he says and
it's way up God I got a follow verse CR
the sad thing too is I'm also not
entirely convinced that the person who's
stealing my [__] in a nicer car wearing
better clothes than me is Aladdin trying
to get
breed it's not always Cas Burgers show
up in like BMWs and stuff yeah dude our
gym got broken into a couple weeks ago
what did they take they just stole a
bunch of random gym equipment oh man
just random [__] that looks like it be
sold or I don't even know could it not
have been a rival gym it could have been
like barbells
taking silver [__] just hella
random Niche like gym equipment that's
like oh okay all right well I [__] that
sucks yeah like they just stole a
trampoline we had a trampoline in there
like a mini one they took that I don't
know what the [__] that's how they got
out of the place they just bounced out
while holding
it remember when the internet when the
internet came out and like economic the
the the you know the almost like um the
way that we view tectonic plates under
the Earth Earth the economic tectonic
plates were shifting and people were
going like nah man this internet [__] is
just some new fad thing you got to get
back to the basics right stick to the
core fundamentals of the economy and
then those guys got destroyed like
[__] Macy's and Sears and JC panties
and the malls and Westfield and all
those guys got killed right the people
who embraced Innovation the next thing
web 3 all this stuff's going on right
now it's the same exact thing it's just
been misappropriated frankly to the
movement like this stuff it needs time
to to obviously incubate and become good
but it when it becomes good you'll be
too late to to really making the money
on the on the game so that's what it's
all about baby it's all about being
early not being late and scooping the
dip scooping the dip baby crypto Corner
let's [__] go let's do it again let's
win but the biggest thing true too is
just realizing that you know your money
is being printed into Oblivion you can
go ahead and pack into a SA has got all
you want you're losing purchasing power
every [__] year you don't even know
it they're stealing from you they hate
you hate you that's my hype man right
there that's right I got him nice and
wrecked on
Luna and we're going to do it
again